uh how big of a deal are the negative
effects of nsaids i understand they can
blunt hypertrophy but to what degree
is the occasional mid-hangover ibuprofen
really killing my gains
and for this one i
i kind of think that the negative impact
of nsaids on strength and hypertrophy i
think that's largely been overblown
um most of the studies that
are investigating that so so just one
general thing about research is that
once a body of literature is developed
pretty well then you start getting
more nuanced studies that are kind of
trying to paint in the details so
for example maybe a dose response type
study but to justify something like that
generally the early studies in a body of
literature are are
slightly extreme to verify that a
potential effect exists that warrants
looking into further so in the case of
the nsaid literature
this is something that gets talked about
a lot but there's there's not actually a
ton of studies on this
uh and and the studies that are out
there do tend to show
that
using nsaids during resistance training
does blunt hypertrophy outcomes
and some of the effects
are are pretty notable so it might
reduce hypertrophy by anywhere from
one-third to two-thirds of what you
could otherwise expect without nsaids um
so that that seems fairly notable but
the thing to keep in mind is the dosages
used in those studies for the nsaids are
quite high
um
and generally they're either being used
every training day or every day
so
you know
i think people
hear that and they say like they
compartmentalize that as like oh nsaids
are bad i have a headache but i can't
take an ibuprofen because that's going
to kill my gains that's not what's being
studied it's looking at
like chronic long-term use of quite high
doses of nsaids so you know if you need
to take some nsaids just on a one-off
basis because you know you got a joint
ache you got a headache you have a
hangover like that's
i assume that's fine and most
importantly that hasn't been researched
um
so you know the stuff that's out there
shows that like ah there's there's maybe
a notable negative effect if you're
using a lot of this stuff very
consistently uh chronically
but i think that lower doses probably
not a huge deal um
and i think that occasional uses also
probably not a huge deal um
but
the like that's just now what the
research is looking at to this point
um
one thing to note as well is i think
that it's
largely reflective of like a hormetic
response so
hormesis is basically the idea that for
a particular
input
uh
the the input itself might exist on a
bell curve and there is an optimal level
of whatever that input is for the output
that you're interested in and it's it's
most frequently hermesis is most most
generally comes up when you're talking
about uh like stress or
um
like like physiological stressors so in
this case we're talking about
inflammation and so
some degree of post-exercise
inflammation is beneficial for the
muscle remodeling and hypertrophy
response
and so if you really really blunt that
with high doses of nsaids now you're
kind of to one side of the hormetic
curve and you don't get the the
magnitude of outcome you're interested
in
if inflammation on the other hand is way
too high that can also have negative
effects so there's been
either one or two studies looking at
nsaid usage in elderly people uh or not
elderly but older people doing
resistance training and in at least one
of those studies they found that nsaids
when paired with resistance training
actually improved hypertrophy outcomes
so
older people tend to have higher
baseline levels of inflammation and it
it could be that they're to the other
side of that hormetic curve maybe
inflammation is too high and using some
insects to bring that down actually has
a beneficial effect so
you know i i think that ultimately
that's sort of the relationship you're
dealing with so there's a range of
inflammation that could be occurring
and you need some amount of it but not
none of it and not to the most of it so
i think if you're using low doses of
nsaids to knock down some sort of
inflammatory response a little bit
you're probably just shifting yourself
along that hormetic curve very slightly
it's probably not going to have that
much of an effect especially if it's
only used intermittently that is
that is my assumption i i think
most people
who aren't just using high doses of
nsaids every day probably just don't
even need to worry about it um
but again this body of literature is
relatively young and there haven't been
studies to kind of flesh out all of
those details dose response work etc so
um
at this point we don't know for sure but
but that is my supposition like most
most people probably don't need to worry
about it
the studies in older adults do you
happen to know if they were uh untrained
at the time of the study i think they
were because you know like we talked
about
we do expect you know systemic
inflammation to go up with age
regular
engage you know regularly engaging in
exercise and physical activity can
attenuate that age-related increase in
inflammation but is unlikely to blunt it
fully so that's an important thing to
keep in mind yes